emails unhelpful vice with Bobby and
kalila alright sagar belly my boyfriend
and I have been together since 2008 when
we started dating I was 15 and now I'm
23 we've grown up together love each
other a lot he graduated from UCLA in
2014 and I graduated from LMU in 2015
magna [ __ ] lotta koala might appreciate I
do appreciate that he's going to
prestigious law school this fall and I
agree to move with him in this summer
since law school was so time intensive I
will be supporting us financially for
the next three years he hasn't asked me
to marry him yet and although that
doesn't bother me so much I feel like
I'm making a big of a commitment to him
I would be nice for him to make an equal
commitment to me I love him dearly and I
know he's one he's the one but after
almost eight years if he doesn't know
that he wants to spend the rest of the
lot his life with me maybe I shouldn't
be making this leap I'm not in
self-involved or anything but I know I'm
like a strong la7 I'm half Arab half
white Texan with blondish hair tan skin
a slender physique and a symmetrical
face example exotic looking like kalila
did you write this so not symmetrical
though and could do well for myself in
the dating and my assumptions okay am ia
fool for moving forward without a ring
Thanks her name is H hey H don't make
assumptions that he doesn't even want to
marry you he's just busy women go I
wanted you know it's very difficult like
I'm going about I want to marry you to
kalila I don't I don't really care if
you do or not found it out baby I'm so
[ __ ] rude once you set it like that
no I don't that to me that is not a
measure like I was telling you [ __ ]
[ __ ] that I want to [ __ ] marry her
like I don't want you know me and then
it's like now I feel like [ __ ] about it
listen to me so no now we're not gonna
get married
let's help age I'm good I'm gonna help
age but listen okay
I thought I wanted to marry kalila but I
guess she doesn't want to so um but even
though she doesn't want to whatever in
my head I'm like I'm gonna marry her but
right now is not the right time to say
timing I what is your advice on that
sorry just sit the [ __ ] down for a few
more seconds Jesus I think they've been
sick she's been with this guy since she
was 15 she's only 23 yes she has all her
ducks in line I say don't fall into the
trap of marrying this guy now maybe
write up a contract if you're gonna
financially support him for the next
three years write up a contract or an
agreement to where you're going to be
you're going to see some of that money
back but don't trap yourself by getting
married at 23 please don't I know I know
you know in what I'm saying is probably
kind of anti love story you know people
do want to believe that the people that
they meet when they're 15 is the people
that it does exist and that does happens
me know my grandparents you know were
together since they were 13 and I get
that and it does happen and it is
special but what I'm saying is you're in
LA 7ui your ducks in line you're you're
you're a hot chick don't get married at
23 see what else is out there if you
love this guy stay with him but and and
and find some way to make yourself feel
secure about supporting him financially
for the next three years and maybe
you'll see some of that money back but
don't worry about the marriage part as a
matter of fact it's blessing in disguise
that he hasn't asked you yet okay that's
good let's get married
baby yeah you know what I changed my
mind I changed my mind and it's fine
one final quick question this is from
Andre from Portugal my question is for
you in the pack podcast what are your
favorite fight scenes ever they can be
from movies TVs anime manga or whatever
oh I know mine I know mine too is yours
raid two kitchen scene
that's a good one favorite ever mine is
this old boy hallways in the reason
being is because there's no cuts if you
see the scene he fights I don't know
like 50 guys in the hallway one take
with one tank all the way through even
bill burr says that's his favorite scene
in terms of the movie I know what you
talked about it before you have never
seen old boy and it's a problem and you
have to watch it tonight actually now
maybe after you
[Music]